Mika's with us in Waco Texas a mica how
are you I'm honored I'm also very
nervous it's okay we've never lost a
patient how can I help
well baby steps we won - now we're back
down to one
we just got an IRS bill and we've almost
paid off the first one and now we got
this on my husband's job is very labor
intense and he is just now coming on
board I think gizelle for over a year
and he's just not coming on board and
I'm a little worried about telling him
about this why are you why are you
ending up behind with the IRS how's this
happening no I mean really mechanically
are you is somebody working
self-employed you're not doing quarterly
estimates no no hang on you're
withholding no what had happened was I
was stupid enough to listen to somebody
and they said though they could do
creative math and they said well you can
you can claim business as deductibles
and then of course we've never done this
before and through ignorance we got we
got into a little bit of a pickle and we
accept that and we're getting it paid
off but okay so you want so you miss
filed you're you you had to you did not
have enough withheld because you
believed you had deductions that you
didn't have and that got you behind once
now what is the second one well and we
didn't realize what was going on until
later than the IRS started sending us
you're being audited and sorry that okay
what's going on and
stop stop stop stop something this
doesn't make sense okay
last year you filed your taxes a year
ago and you discovered and you did
listen and you discovered that you were
short because you screwed up okay yeah I
got where that one comes from but once
you discovered you were short you didn't
go correct it no no we did collect it
this is two years back we're taking care
of our mistake from two years back then
how did you get a new one you just got a
fresh IRS bill that you didn't see
coming that you don't want to tell your
husband about that's what you told me no
I know I knew this was coming I I just
was hoping that I could get out from
under some debt before it hit okay
listen there's a high correlation
between people who work together with
their spouse and whether or not they're
able to build wealth your husband and
you working together and always knowing
both of you knowing everything that's
going on is the only possible way to
have a high-quality marriage and Bill
wealth it really is I mean the
statistical evidence that that if you if
you lie to your husband it doesn't work
out and the statistical evidence if he
doesn't get on board in the two of you
don't work together to solve all
financial problems but so far you've
been gizelle intense he's not really on
board and you're hiding stuff from him
or attempted to hide stuff from him and
see these are two different things but
they both indicate you've got to get on
the same page so I think you sit down
with him and you turn off the television
put the kids to bed if you got kids and
you look deeply into his eyes and go
enough enough I'm tired of doing this by
myself
I need you to be a man I'm tired of
being mommy and you're the little boy
and I need you get on board with me
enough and you know he's not a bad guy
he's just ignoring this and thinks it's
gonna be okay to the point that now you
feel ashamed because something's out of
control and you're doing it by yourself
and so the two of you need to be working
together and any surprises you have the
two of you fight them together no you do
not hide this from him and yes you use
this as an opportunity to pull him
further on board and I mean he has
really no right to criticize you because
he's not doing anything
if he's not helping how does he have a
seat to criticize so I mean he don't
like weights maybe in hell maybe he
ought to get involved hello so yeah
that's what's going on but now you can
never deceive you can never lie you can
never hide stuff from your spouse and
and workout for I mean it didn't it I
mean who wants to be lied to
who wants to have stuff hidden from him
only somebody's weird I've got problems
that's all he didn't want to even want
you hiding stuff from him you don't
wanna be lied to I don't want I don't
want Sharon not telling me something
because it's unpleasant you know
no thank you that's not how
relationships work especially the one
you're supposed to be closest to on the
planet your spouse so yeah you tell him
everything all of you tell each other
everything
you know 37% of Americans live their
spouse about money according to a survey
that's hard for me to bleed but when you
think about it number one cause of
divorce in America is money fights and
money problems and 52% of Americans
ended marriages end in divorce so that
kind of does make sense if you think
about it but it also indicates that line
your spouse probably is not a good idea
yellow this is the Dave Ramsey show